one of the things that we learned early
on was that deep interdisciplinarity was
absolutely critical for what we were
trying to do my team had an
anthropologist a designer there was me a
couple of computer scientists and
engineers and a linguist and it really
took this broad set of expertise to come
together to try to understand well what
is it we're really trying to do here
what do people need what do they want
what is the context of their lives that
can actually make this fit good
solutions to problems can come in all
forms and it doesn't necessarily have to
be technical per se and often if you
overemphasize the technical bits you
wind up missing the gold you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen Hughes Inga
[Music]
dr. edu Trull is a principal researcher
in the ability group of Microsoft
Research and he's convinced that great
technology should be available to
everyone working in the fields of
accessibility and information and
communication technologies for
development
aka ICT 4d his research has explored
computing solutions for people across
the resource and ability spectrum both
here and around the world today dr.
kucho gives us an overview of his work
in the disability and inclusive design
space explains the vital importance of
interdisciplinarity a fancy way of
saying many ways of thinking in many
ways of knowing and tells us how a dumb
phone beat a smart tablet in rural India
and what that meant to researchers that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
edie
cue Trull welcome to the podcast thanks
we're gonna be fluid today because it
seems nearly everything in your life and
work overlaps so let's get the flow
going give us the virtual earth 3d view
of the work you do as a principal
researcher in the ability group in MSR
what gets edq Trull up in the morning
well I'll say that what really gets me
up in the morning these days is we have
new kittens and so I get up every
morning whenever they're walking over my
face but I don't think that's really
what you're asking right now I am a
principal researcher and the ability
group as you said and what we're really
all about is looking at how can
technology improve and affect the lives
making lives better for people with
various kinds of disabilities and this
could be from motor disabilities sensory
disabilities intellectual disabilities a
whole range of things but there's a
general sense that information
technology is uniquely positioned to
help people have better lives in this
way and we think we can maybe try to
figure out what that is so the research
focuses specifically on these audiences
that we'll talk about further on in the
podcast give us a little bit more about
your particular heart for this if you
will I would say that for me there is a
very strong sense that whatever the kind
of work that I do needs to really be
influencing and effecting people who
maybe don't get the same kinds of
chances that I've had that other people
have and that are often ignored and so
an opportunity that I've had here at
Microsoft research is to try to pivot
our gaze from just the information
worker or the people that are really
wealthy and then have all the money and
all the tech and the gadgets into people
that have been a little bit overlooked
well I usually wait to ask how you got
into what you're doing and how you ended
up at Microsoft
research until later in the interview
but I want to move that question up
because the answer is inextricably
linked to the other things we're going
to talk about today so let's start with
the ED q chill story from your initial
academic training in cognitive
neuroscience to where you are and what
you're doing today it's a fascinating
path give us a little tour of the
journey okay well let me start when I
was 12 years old and I bought my first
computer it was a TI 99 for a computer
that I bought with my lawnmower money
that I had gotten over the summer and
from that moment forward I knew that
there was something special about
computers but then as I got a little
older I started to realize that there
was actually something special about
this computer I was born with in my head
and so I wanted to understand more about
well how did that work fast forward a
number of years and I'm in grad school
and I really had the starry-eyed
optimism that I could understand how
this three pounds of pudding in my brain
was going to lead to really
understanding of consciousness so my
thesis during grad school was on the
neural basis of spatial attention in the
parietal cortex okay so that should give
you a hint that I was kind of far away
from figuring out how the brain gives
rise to consciousness and so as I left
grad school it became clear to me that
to answer the questions that I really
wanted to answer it was going to be
another 50 or 100 years and so I started
casting around to figure out well what
else could I be doing with my time and
my life and my energy and questions that
I wanted to ask that would maybe give me
a little more immediate kinds of answers
so I called it my friend Mary Shaw
Winsky who I had heard was doing
usability research at Microsoft and she
had just moved to MSR and she was doing
some work with Erik Horvitz and some
other people on looking at interruptions
how do people manage their attention
while they're working with computers and
she said I need some help on this maybe
you can come up and do some studies for
me and that sounded pretty good to me so
I did and next thing you know I'm
spending in the next nine years at
Microsoft Research doing work in
human-computer interaction or HCI okay
now one of those things that came up and
this was a big highlight for me early on
was that I managed to get to work with
really one of my heroes his woman named
Susan doom a she was here at MSR and we
had this simple question which was why
is it that I can search the entire
worldwide web and get an answer in under
a second yet when I want to search my
email and my file system it takes 10
minutes to grep through the whole thing
and so we were really asking so how can
we make this better and so what we did
was we just took some of the
technologies from web search and we just
said well why can't we just apply that
to our own stuff and so we created a
system called stuff I've seen and the
stuff I've seen basically just uses
modern indexing techniques on your own
stuff so that was a fascinating
experience for me and it actually led to
the window search that millions of
people use today right now and so that's
the basic technology that that was from
right all right here you were doing
search stuff and working with Mary
working with Susan etc then because I
know at the end of the story what
happened now so the next thing was
inbound in 2005 MSR had started a lab in
Bangalore and this was at the time a
tiny little lab and I had been in
contact with one of the founders is the
fellow named Kintaro Toyama and as part
of the new lab Kintaro was heading up a
new research group and it was called the
technology for emerging markets or TEM
and the temp with focused on trying to
understand how computing could help to
improve the lives of people living with
very serious constraints and when I say
constraints I mean things like resource
constraints money mm-hmm but it might be
infrastructure like they don't have
access to broadband or no literacy or
it's oh it's educational constraints
even electricity so all of these things
together how can technology help these
folks now at the time they were just
starting to look at this and they were
looking at things like kiosks that you
would have in the middle of a village
and maybe that people could all share to
use and get maybe agricultural
information and what they were finding
was that a lot of the problems that they
were running into weren't really
technical problems they were a lot more
about understanding what people really
needed and then how to fit the
technology into their lives and so
basically that's an HDI problem yeah and
so I was chatting with him and over the
next couple of years he basically said
well why don't you come out and play
with us for a little bit and I said that
sounds fun and so my wife and I left and
we were gonna spend about four months
just spending some time in Bangalore and
looking at a bunch of these problems now
I had been there for about two months
and I was having a great time we were
doing some really cool research and I
was having coffee with Kintaro
and he told me I just thought I should
tell you that I'm leaving Microsoft I'm
gonna go write a book I was like oh okay
that's cool and he's like do you know
anybody would want this job and I said
no but I'll ask around and over the
course of the next couple of weeks we
were looking to hire who the next person
would be and at some point they turned
and looked at me and they said well do
you want to do this so I went and talked
to my wife and she was like sure what
the hell so we came back to Seattle we
sold the house we sold the cars we sold
most of our stuff we packed up the
to cats and carriers and we moved to
Bangalore and I managed to take over the
technology for a marching markets group
for the next several years well let's
talk in more depth about the six years
you spent at MSR India working on
technology for emerging markets so your
focus was to put it simply making tech
for people that people don't usually
make tech for or they do but it doesn't
really fit them so you told us a little
bit about how you got there talk about
why you went and what you learned sure
so the technology for emerging markets
group really is focused on an area in
academia or scholarship that's called
ICT 4d and what that stands for is
information and communication
technologies for development and the
development there is not really sort of
the computer science terms of
development this is really global
development like the idea of global
economic social development now when I
went there this was really just at the
beginning of when mobile phones were
starting to take off so this is right
around 2008-2009 and they were starting
to blow up throughout the country but
they hadn't really deeply penetrated
much of the hinterlands of India and of
course they were still very expensive so
most of the work that we were doing was
really focused on computers and laptops
and tablets now since then a lot of the
stuff has very much shifted into phones
at the time for these populations it was
very very little so what we were really
interested in was understanding how
technology can be used for achieving
goals having to do with education with
agriculture with global health with
financial services for the poor now one
of the things that we learned early on
was that deep interdisciplinarity was
absolutely critical for what we were
trying to do my team has
an anthropologist a designer there was
me a couple of computer scientists and
engineers and a linguist and it really
took this broad set of expertise to come
together to try to understand well what
is it we're really trying to do here
what do people need what do they want
what is the context of their lives that
could actually make this fit good
solutions to problems can come in all
forms and it doesn't necessarily have to
be technical per se and often if you
overemphasize the technical bits you
wind up missing the gold so let me give
you an exam fairly early on we were
playing with this technology that used a
digital slate and so what we had done
was we had adapted this thing for this
domain for healthcare workers that were
monitoring childhood malnutrition in
really rural remote India right now we
thought it was a perfect solution
because it was really easy to learn it
was based on the same skills and
techniques that all the healthcare
workers were using anyway so we were
like this is a home run this is
beautiful so we were going to deploy it
and at the same time we were going to be
deploying yet another group from our
friends at de magie
they were going to be deploying a
similar kind of a solution but their's
was just based on a standard dumb phone
so really a feature phone so what we
called it now their solution was cool
because it was cheaper than ours but
it's really hard to use I mean you had
to triple tap text-entry
it was in Hindi and Hindi triple tap
text let me tell you it was really
difficult for the workers to kind of
manage it and the other thing is that
they were really very attracted to our
cool sexy tablet and so we were like
this is a home run there's no way to
Maggie's gonna really walk away with
this
so we deployed the thing we do our
training we leave we come back in three
weeks and nobody is using the tablet and
everyone is using the phone
what happened was there were a few
things first the phone was really useful
as a phone so many of these health care
workers were women they didn't have
phones themselves we were handing them a
phone so that their sister from the
neighboring village could call them
periodically so that was one thing
another thing was that the camera on the
phones turned out to be really useful
almost as an adjunct tool in their jobs
because many times they would be trying
to say okay well I've got a child they
really need some kind of nutritional
care something like that so then their
job was then to turn to some other
workers from another agency to say you
need to provide them with the
appropriate nutritional supplements and
often they would get pushback they
wouldn't do that
so then what they started doing was
taking the camera on the phone and
taking a picture of the person and
recording this interaction and
threatening the other person that they
had evidence that they were denying
these kids and in the final two things
which just in retrospect is of course
this is going to be true was that
there's an a repair ecology for all
these feature phones things break you're
in the middle of nowhere that's dusty
there's all kinds of problems and so we
had a number of these health care
workers that would take our tablet to
the local repair guy in a nearby village
and he take one look at our tablet and
say I'm not touching that thing but they
would get their phones and they would
work on them they would fix them and
then the final piece about this was
power many of these villages had power
for maybe three hours a day we didn't
realize it at the time but our tablets
actually took six hours to fully charge
and so for many of the workers they
would come to work with an only
partially charged tablet that hadn't run
out in the middle of the day and then
they would be embarrassed whenever
they're trying to do their work so they
just fell back on the phone so anyway
that's an example of by paying attention
in much larger context in the actual
deployment of use
and sits you you learned so much more
about what you might be able to be doing
and where you need to be moving your
design and how to think about what your
interventions going to be so I happen to
know that after six years you came back
here 2016 and started working in the
Redman lab again on technology for
another group that's been traditionally
underserved by tech I'm gonna let you
tell the story but I want to tee it up
by this little anecdote that you stole
me that makes me laugh he started as a
group of two people and basically we're
told that two is a duo not a band
however the stars were in alignment for
the work that you wanted to do and so
the ability group was born tell us your
version of that story ad all right well
when I first started thinking about
leaving India I had had some
conversations with my friend Mary Morris
now both of us had come to the
conclusion that well whatever we did
next it really needed to be something
that well first it was something we
really cared about that it really
mattered to us and to that we felt could
really help improve people's lives in a
meaningful way she'd been doing a little
bit of work and accessibility and as we
talked more it became clear that there
was like a real opportunity for impact
here at Microsoft in that space now
Satya had just become CEO and he was
repeating our mission statement which is
to empower every person in every
organization on the planet to achieve
more that means every person and this
diversity and inclusion notion was
really in the air but there wasn't
really any work at MSR at the time that
was focusing on this space now Rico
malov are I think you've had him on the
podcast earth yeah and Mary you know and
so he was doing some amazing work at the
time with ALS but that was about it
there really wasn't any other kind of
going on so I moved back to Redmond and
we pitched the idea of our management we
said we want to start a regrouping
accessibility and we think this is the
right time MSR is the place to do it
let's do it they looked at us and they
went well you guys do that that's great
but two people in a group so we put our
heads down and we just started working
and by the next year we were
collaborating with actually quite a few
researchers in several different groups
all sort of related to accessibility and
during that time there were three fairly
senior researchers that all basically
came up to us and said can i play and by
that point we kind of had a quorum so
senior management sort of looked at what
we were doing and they said you know
this is something that MSR should invest
in and so they handed us the group and
the ability group is born and so Mary
manages the group and the other members
include a fella named Jon pong there's a
guy named Andy bagel Mike Barnet and the
most recent person who joined was Mort
as not well so whether you're in another
country or here in the US your research
interesting geared toward equipping
people who've been to some degree or
another for one reason or another
marginalized by the tech world so when
we talked before you told me that you
based your work on three guiding
principles we've sort of alluded to them
now but I like how you framed them when
we talked before so I want you to tell
our listeners what they are and how they
inform the work that you do ed sure well
the first of these is the work needs to
be deeply interdisciplinary now when I
say that engineers and computer
scientists have an amazing skill set for
solving certain kinds of really well
structured problems but people are
complicated yeah and their lives are
really complex and the situations in
which they live are not always tuned for
that so this really requires a broader
palette of expertise now in ability
had the same kind of broad spectrum of
social scientists and computer
scientists and me a psychologist and by
combining these kinds of disciplines
together it creates almost an alchemy
that you can't get when you just have
these monocultures exploration so that's
the first one the second key pillar is
that it has to be anchored in lies and
the needs of the people this includes
the context of living the culture the
infrastructure and so much more about
what defines the place that we are and
how we live the idea behind that is that
there's really no policy or design that
you should be engaging in without the
full participation of members of the
groups with people that are going to be
using your technology the third thing is
rigorous evaluation everything we do we
want to explore how good is it really so
for any innovation prototype new idea
any of that stuff we have to carefully
and as hard as it is for us
dispassionately study whether and how
it's going to be used by the people its
intended for and so often that means
guide posting dead ends as well as
promising places to go so that people
don't tread on the really terrible ideas
it also gives us a certain credibility
in the marketplace to be able to say to
people we had this cool idea but there
are some problems and let's be very
honest about those problems and to be
honest about when that's true and that
isn't true actually it turns out to be
really important yeah when they're using
your tablet to serve dinner on instead
of exactly
[Music]
let's talk now about some specific
threads of active research in the
ability group that you're involved in
tell us from your perspective what's new
what's cool what's promising what you
find exciting and why alright well I
think one of the things that I find most
exciting right now is you know if you
think about virtual reality and
augmented reality or here at Microsoft
to collect mixed reality there's an
enormous hype there and one of the
really interesting things about the work
that's being done in that space is that
it's intensely visual and there hasn't
been a lot of thought about what that
means to engage in a virtual reality or
augmented reality kind of experience if
you're disabled and there are a number
of different threads for the ways in
which this might fall out so some of the
projects were working on are very much
around people with visual disabilities
but it actually goes beyond that and it
goes into if your motor disabled like
you've got maybe weakness in your head
how do you wear this giant headset VR
tends to require you to be able to look
around and move easily to use both hands
in controllers and things what happens
when you can't do that yeah if you are
low vision then you put on this thing
and you're still low vision you can't
even wear your glasses so I would say
that there are a few really fun threads
that we're working on now so one of
these is a project that we've just
wrapped up and that I'm excited to say
is an open-source so you can download it
and use it this is called seeing VR the
idea behind this is to create a set of
tools for people who are low vision now
this is not blind these are people that
have essentially uncorrectable visual
problems yeah so when you have these
issues
Villar as it exists today just is a
blurry screen so what seeing VR does is
it's a plugin for unity that allows you
to do about nine or eleven different
kinds of things to improve that things
like magnifiers you'll do edge
enhancement and we can do things like
condensing to avoid your blind spots now
the cool thing about all this is that it
doesn't require the developer to do
anything we just take the raw input
that's taken from the system that's
generating and rendering to the screen
and then we can manipulate it so that's
seeing VR another project that's related
to VR and this is also for people that
are blind actually and this is a project
called the cane troller the idea behind
this project is that people who are
blind particularly if they've been blind
awhile will go through a process of
training for using a white cane we had a
question which was well if you were
blind and you were put into a vr space
could we create a virtual white cane
that was fully haptic there gives you
the experience of navigating walls and
objects within a virtual space that are
not really there and we were able to do
that and it turns out that when people
use our little virtual or what we call
the cane troller then they're able to
actually start to understand a virtual
space without seeing anything so that's
two of them that are in the pure VR
space now another thing that's quite
exciting when you think about ar-ar-ar
is augmented reality and so this is
where you can use a phone or you can use
a headset that combines images of the
real world with artificial things and so
you're augmenting what's in the reality
so hololens is the sort of the Microsoft
example of this so it's really super
cool
there are other versions of augmented
reality and one of those is produced by
the enable group here at MSR and it's
called soundscape now this is a little
app that you can download for your
iPhone and what it does is it provides
spatialized audio to tell you about
things around you as you're out walking
in the world the notion behind this is
not really to give you turn by turn
navigation information but to really
give you an enhanced understanding of
the world around you things that you
might miss because you can't see and one
of the things I find very exciting about
this is that it's using a different
modality and augmenting the reality on
top of that by using spatialized audio
now this is something that can be used
by everybody
right and I'm actually quite thrilled
with starting to explore what is non
visual augmented reality what does that
mean how do we think about that right so
I'm gonna pivot a little bit and talk
about another set of projects that we
just started working on and this is
stuff that's still quite new and so I
can't talk to about too much of it but I
can give you a teaser and the idea
behind this work is to start understand
neuro diversity in the workplace now
I've been talking about things like
sensory and motor impairments but there
are other kinds of impairments and one
of those is people with autistic
spectrum disorder or autism they're
often called neuro-diverse
and neuro-diverse folks have an
interesting time in the workforce one
common issue that they experienced is a
difficulty in thinking about emotion and
processing that from other people and
even how they present that emotion so
we're starting to explore are there ways
that technology can help improve their
experience as they're sort of managing
just their day-to-day life so you can't
really say much I'm just gonna leave
that there I will say that part of what
we're doing with this
is trying to create tools that just
provide a little bit of insight for
people that are on the spectrum to sort
of provide their own agency and the way
that they manage this information it's
not like we're trying to fix them really
the notion is we can get some insight
about what might be going on here and we
might be able to give you some clues
about it mm-hmm and then we're gonna
leave it up to you to figure out what
you want to do with that all right well
we're gonna have to come back to you in
a year or so and find out where that's
landed look forward to I do too
I want to touch on one more because an
Paradiso had brought up a couple of
ideas when she was talking to me about
Steve Gleason and the I controlled
wheelchair and so on but we also got to
talking about communication disabilities
and when it's difficult for someone to
speak tell us about the is it AAC AAC
augmentative and alternative
communication there's actually a long
history of AC work that's been done and
actually this is for nonverbal children
with autism they often will use these
kinds of systems people that can't speak
clearly in different ways they will use
them and as you mentioned people with
ALS because as they lose their ability
to speak they still have you know
complete cognitive clarity and they want
to interact with folks now one of the
cool things that and and that group is
done is they've been really working on
this I control notion of communication
of being able to sort of type with your
eyes and you can create you know Steve
will write speeches using these systems
and you know but if you've ever heard
Steve or for instance Stephen Hawking
write use these systems it's this
monotone computer voice now you could
imagine what it's like if you're trying
to tell a joke using one of these
systems it just falls flat it's
impossible to be sarcastic using these
systems and one of the things that we
really were thinking about was how
can we enhance the expressive palate of
an AAC kind of system to allow people
who are using them to be able to produce
the richer range of emotional content
that we produce which is porosity you
know there's an enormous difference when
I say can you come over here now to my
kid or can you come over here now
actually Steve mentioned that one of the
things that was really hard for him was
being able to yell at his kid I mean if
you're just like get over here now so
what we did was we did a big exploration
of ways in which we could provide this
kind of setting of context and so what
you were talking about with the emojis
is that as he would be producing an
utterance there was a separate keyboard
palette that was sort of sat above the
normal keyboard as he's producing his
text and then he could just sort of
apply different kinds of emotion to it
now we would produce then on the other
side of his screen which was visible by
people that he's talking to different
kinds of emoji that would set the tone
the other thing we could do with that
which was kind of cool is we could start
to shape the prosody of the text in the
computer-generated speech so we could
create up tones for may be happy kinds
of sounds or if you were trying to say
this is sad then you could have falling
tones it's still quite early and it's
not amazing yet but it's so much better
than it was well you know I have forever
said they need to have a sarcasm font
for my emails but they don't all right
well it's time for unintended
consequences and that's the part of the
podcast where we ask what could possibly
go wrong is there anything about the
work you do that keeps you up at night
any concerns that you'd share with us I
would say that the fundamental thing is
that no matter how you know air quotes
noble your intentions are
when you're trying to work with and on
behalf of people that have a really
different life experience than you do
then there's always a hazard that you're
gonna build in all your own biases and
values and desires into whatever you're
doing and so the solutions that you
think you're finding answers to problems
that people actually have maybe just
solutions to problems that I think they
have or that I think I would have if I
were in their place and there's always
going to be a threat that the
technologies that you have that you're
producing are gonna snap back and bite
people on the butt in really non-obvious
ways mm-hmm I've been doing a lot of
work with cameras like wearable cameras
for blind and low-vision people now you
can already see where this is going I
can saw only you know now you could
imagine all kinds of benefits that this
could provide but as soon as you're
wearing a camera around that video is
going somewhere it does provide enormous
potential benefits but it also opens up
a profound level of surveillance and
intrusion that can really hit people
hard and if we don't think super clearly
about it then it almost certainly will
happen and even if we do think about it
it's probably gonna happen
the thing that you just said is
something that almost everyone in this
booth has said here's the problem and we
need to be thinking deeply about this
how this gets back to my three pillars
because one of the best ways to help
mitigate this is to actually deeply
understand the people that you're
working with and more than that to take
multiple perspectives of that if all you
take is just a brief study
sort of
with an engineering mindset on what is
the problem and how do I solve it rather
than what is the aftermath or how is
this actually going to be used so you
know it's this kind of thing that
without really sort of taking the time
and the effort to sort of study the
context and the lives that people have
it's really easy to screw it up
you told us a bit of your personal story
upfront about your path from academia to
the work you're doing today but lately
I've been digging a little deeper on the
personal side and asking people to tell
us something we might not know about
them especially as it might pertain to
how it impacted your career as a
researcher do you have anything to share
the one thing I would point out was sort
of an accidental thing that I fell into
near the end of grad school and there's
this organization called the mind and
life Institute now the mind and life
Institute was convened by a group of
neuroscientists and the Dalai Lama and
essentially what they wanted to do was
to create a bridge between Western views
and understanding of consciousness and
mind and sort of this reductionist
scientific idea and the eastern
conceptions of consciousness as evolved
over basically 2,000 years of deep
practice and was really deep
introspective techniques of meditation
you know I was really interested in this
space and somehow I wound up getting
invited to a couple of week long silent
meditations of scientists and so that
the Buddhists were basically saying if
you're gonna try to study this stuff you
can't possibly just use Western tools
but you really need to understand where
we're coming from
come immerse yourself in this stuff for
a little bit so I did that and it was
deeply impactful to me and my own life
and the way that I thought about
knowledge
and about sort of I mean at a higher
level what is evidence and what is truth
and how do we think about that and to
some extent this is what pushed me
farther along with my beating the drama
round interdisciplinarity because it was
this notion that there is no really one
way to know something there are many
ways of knowing and that introspective
or intuitive approaches can have a
Norma's amount of validity
especially when allied with sort of the
Western reductionist sort of pure
scientific view and I would say that
that experience sort of had ripple
effects throughout much of the rest of
my career and a second way in which it
really had ripple effects was a
realization that anything that I do or
don't do
has ethical implications and to actually
consciously address the fact that
whenever I am choosing to study or
choosing not to study actually has an
influence in the full ethical experience
of my life and the way that I experience
it and the way that I'm influencing
other people we reached the end of our
time together which makes me sad because
this has been one of those grinning from
ear to ear head nodding things that
people can't see podcasts I'm gonna give
you the last word and now's your chance
to say anything you want by way of
advice inspiration wisdom even warning
to our listeners so what might you say
to emerging researchers that might be
interested in what you do okay I've got
three things the first is to look at the
places in between
it's the liminal spaces the things that
are between disciplines epistemologies
ways of knowing that's where the real
action is that's where you're gonna find
the next big thing
and the entire training of academia in
research is to go super deep super
directly down into the giant body of
knowledge and the discipline they are
getting credentialed in and what I
really want to tell people is that's
great and you need to have that ability
under your belt but that's not where
your real success is going to be it's
really going to be looking at where is
nobody else looking or where is sort of
the between things that's the first one
the second one is for God's sake don't
take yourself too seriously life is
beautiful it's fun it's unexpected and
you have to be able to let it be that
and to revel in it so that's the second
thing and the third thing is a rule that
I've developed over the years I'm old
now so I can say this but my really big
rule is surround yourself with nice
people people that you enjoy so that's
my three add cute role thank you for
coming on the podcast it's been
absolutely delightful thank you so much
[Music]
to learn more about dr. edq trial and
how ability researchers are making
technology for people that people don't
usually make technology for visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]